a housewife poses with a week's worth of
groceries in 1947 this viral social
media post claims that a 1940s housewife
could feed her entire family on just
$12.50 for the whole week doesn't she
look so smug about it too I'm grumpy
about Rising grocery prices so I
understand why this sort of economic
Nostalgia is attractive right now but
does the math add up nope as Economist
Jeremy horal points out when Life
Magazine published this photo in 1947
the average American wage was about $1
hour today the average wage in America
is about $29 an hour so the 12 hours
that a 1947 worker put in to get that
grocery hall now equals
$350 of pay that's more than double what
the average family spent on groceries
per week in 2022 inflation has made
everyone poor in the past few years but
the fact is that food is much more
affordable today relative to 75 years
ago and food nowadays is a lot better
too look at all the canned veggies in
that photo yuck